nice party it's so good to see everyone
you know I heard that the legends have
quite some parties to mmm so tell me did
you finally you looking for yeah I did a
lot more I think fighting a time to even
helped mmm but dad look I left him flash
because I felt like I was always gonna
be in very shadow but as a legend I I
learned how to be comfortable just being
me I'm so proud of you something I think
you see your sister yes hey everybody
its Charlie so big news is Kid Flash is
leaving both legends of tomorrow and the
flash next season now he didn't say
permanently forever he's just not gonna
be a series regular meaning that he's
only going to appear a couple times so
I'll try to explain what's going on with
that if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
DC videos there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway - all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video a little
while ago they released a promo with
synopsis for the new seasons of each of
the shows like season 4 of Legends and
season 5 of the flash they'd added
Constantine to the poster for legends
but there was no Kid Flash so people are
like is Wally West coming back like
what's the deal do they just want to
make you wonder where he's gonna show up
first because he's a flash character -
then Keenan Lonsdale came out and gave
this pretty definitive statement about
why he chose not to come back and it was
his choice
the legends producers probably would
have brought him back as a series
regular as part of their Constantine arc
next season and obviously he's always
gonna pop up on the flash at least once
or twice per season no matter what
they're doing with the character but
here's the statement I'm just gonna read
what he said here just to put it into
context so he says yo so a lot of you
have now read I'm not returning next
season as a series regular for flash of
legends it's definitely not a total
goodbye or see an ever situation because
wally west will still be around when you
need him most which is probably the
crossovers it's just that now it won't
be full-time anymore i've changed a lot
in the past year as you probably notice
like he changes his appearance pretty
regularly and for infinite reasons my
perspective on life and what i want from
it now is completely different because
of that my heart told
me that it was the right time to
continue my journey on an unknown path
and I'm so damn grateful to both shows
for honoring and respecting that with me
I love Kid Flash I love the family I
made and I'm absolutely in love with the
invaluable lessons that I've learned
along the way
thank you for believing me in rooting
for wall-e to thrive you honestly helped
me see that I did indeed deserve to play
him that right there may be a
stronger actor and he's just you know
thanking everybody anyway I hope you
stick around for the new adventures the
only thing I can promise is magic so a
lot of you know that he has sort of a
separate career as a musician he's
probably gonna be doing a little bit
more of that
he's also been acting in films a little
bit more so it just sounds like he's
focusing on different areas of his
career outside of television a lot of
you will remember that Colton Haynes did
the exact same thing a couple years ago
on arrow like Willa Holland just left
arrow to for pretty much the same reason
like she's like okay you know I've done
all I can do with this character I want
to do other things they're very young
they have like their entire careers
ahead of them so obviously the arrow
verse is gonna continue to exist for a
long time so the characters will always
come back for the big episodes said this
calls for a toss but based on what Kenan
Lonsdale saying was probably gonna
happen with Kid Flash is because we just
got that cliffhanger with noir Allen
isn't that in episode one of the flash
season five he'll get to know Nora like
find out what's going on then I'll go
off to fight starfish somewhere else
stuff like that so that when he does
come back for the crossover like
hopefully he'll come back for the
four-way Batwoman crossover and I don't
think that this is some secret ploy to
put Kid Flash on Titan season 1 like
they've already almost finished shooting
that season so they ever get a speedster
on that TV show it could be Kenan
Lonsdale but they'll probably just wait
a little bit longer and then recast a
different actor to play Wally West or
whichever flash they decide to bring on
but then I would expect Kid Flash to
come back at least once or twice in the
back half of the season for legends in
flash bare minimum once or twice this
season on flash legends maybe once just
during the crossover it just remains to
be seen it's just that they have that
cliffhanger on the flash which is why I
say yeah they probably should bring him
back in episode 1 of the flash just to
wrap that
the weird problem that a lot of the CW
shows have though is that there's always
that couple months time jump like
between seasons 1 and 2 and between
seasons two and three they just went off
and did their own thing like everybody
had their own version of summer vacation
so even if a couple months do go by
hopefully wall-e will stick around in
the first episode just to have like a
moment and a goodbye with his new sister
Jenna because it is his sister now but
really we just want to see what's going
on with Nora like that's really where
the action is which is why I think
they're effectively replacing Wally or
what Wally would normally be doing with
Nora's arc during season five so let me
know in the comments what do you think
about Kid Flash leaving the TV shows
they didn't really use them that much on
flash this season so it's not gonna look
that much different for that TV show but
obviously it's a big loss for legends
but I also think it makes a little bit
easier for them to do some of the
special effects for Constantine spell
weaving because most of their season
will be consumed with monster hunting
like in the way that they hunted down
time anachronisms in previous seasons
next season on legends is basically
gonna be Pokemon with magical creatures
but the other really big news you may
have heard about is we got our first
look at Jason Todd on Titan's and at
Gotham City remember Gotham City is a
location in the Titans universe
different from the Gotham City on the
Gotham TV show I've already done a
couple Red Hood videos but I might do a
reaction video for Jason Todd because
his age is actually pretty notable in
terms of how long it might take him to
become the Red Hood character because
there is a lot of speculation that
they're eventually working their way up
to a Red Hood TV show but obviously you
have to put Jason Todd on the death in
the family arc like first you have to
kill him then he has to come back then
he can be Red Hood then he can go off
into his own TV show and we can get red
hood in the outlaws but speaking of
flashes that they could do on Titan's if
they wanted to do a version of geoff
johns teen titans lineup and they didn't
want to immediately recast wally west as
a different actor they could always do
Bart Allen because they haven't done
Bart on the flash yet they've done Nora
but technically even though she's a lot
like Bart she doesn't have the Bart name
meaning that the name is still free to
be used by another TV show if they
really want to but honestly they got so
many new characters that are introducing
I don't think it's gonna be a big deal
and there was a new rumor that they're
going to be cast
Conner Kent Superboy for Titans in
season 2
[Music]
attaboy so let that blow your mind we're
almost gonna be getting a version of a
live-action Young Justice this extra
sounds pretty badass so hopefully a
trailer for that will drop really soon
I do have new Marvel and DC videos that
I'm working on there's supposed to be an
Aquaman trailer sometime soon if it
drops I will totally do a video for it
but in the meantime click here to
rewatch the How to Train Your Dragon
trailer and click here for brand new
Avengers 4 teaser thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight